Je suis Layla Kassir, la soeur de Latifé Kassir,
tuée par son mari.
Ils étaient divorcés, ça c'est passé il y a 4 ans,
et pour ne pas que les expériences se
répètent avec toutes les mères qui
souffrent, je souhaite que chaque mère,
chaque sœur et de chaque fille pas
encore mariée, pour garantir ses droite,
vienne le 8 mars avec nous à la
manifestation pour que la loi soit adoptée.
Je suis Joséphine, la maman de Christelle
Abou Chakra qui est morte à cause de la
violence de son mari. J'appelle toutes les
femmes à marcher le 8 mars de Mathaf à
Adlié pour dénoncer la violence contre la
femme.
Moi c'est Layla Khoury de Halba.
Je suis la maman de la victime Rola Yaakoub.
Je vous supplie et je vous souhaite que
vous évitiez ce qui m'est arrivé. Venez
tous.
Celui qui a vendu sa conscience, que Dieu
le juge, qu'il soit médecin ou autre.
Je suis la maman de Manal. Je suis la
maman de la victime, qui vivait en rêvant
de ses enfants, de les élever et les voir
grands dans les meilleurs rangs (sociaux)
et tout d'un coup cela nous arrive. Ma fille
est privée de ses enfants, est privée de
nous tous. Quelle mère veut que ces
enfants la pleurent toute la vie?
Que ce soit la mère, le père ou les frères,
on nous a privés nos yeux à force de pleurer.
Aucune mère ne veut ça. Que les voix
s'élève du monde.
Je suis la maman de Fatmé, qui a été tué
par son mari, étouffée, brûlée. J'ai mis
14 jours pour la trouver. Je souhaite que
chaque mère, que chaque fille vienne à la
manifestation dans la rue qui va avoir lieu,
et réclame des droits. Au moins que l'on
protège la femme. C'est le minimum.
J'espère que l'État va entendre nos cris.
J'espère que cet État soit celui de la
justice et de la loi.
S'il faut prendre la rue pour la législation,
on descend!  Retenez le rendez-vous :
Le 8 mars 2014 de 14 h à 15 h. On marche
du musée jusqu'au palais de justice
pour que justice soit faite pour toutes les
femmes. Soyez nombreux.